the other thing that I've never thought  about is just how like girls are bailed  out of every bad decision we make okay  and I didn't really realize that until I  started like like watching The Red Pill  stuff but really in society every bad  decision women make were bailed out of  like if you if you sleep around we have  birth control if you get pregnant the  government bails you out or he'll bail  you out and then even if you like if you  leave him you get half or you get child  support and then some simple bail you  out after that and then and then on top  of that like  um if you're homeless there's women's  shelters so it's like literally every  bad decision women make like we're  bailed out and like men pay for it yeah